in the lobby of financial feasts Plaza
Nate and Stacey are with us hey guys how
are you hey welcome welcome
now what city do you guys live in
Cincinnati Ohio fun and you're in
Nashville today to do your debt-free
scream right here in our lobby that's
correct I love it I love it I love it
way to go very cool so how much debt
have you paid off one hundred and eight
thousand dollars way to go how long did
that take
just about five and a half years okay
good good is that your house and
everything
it isn't yeah no it's not no student
loans car debts credit cards you name it
we had it Wow
household income during the five years I
started out at 125 when we started the
program went down to 77 and then went
back up to 128 over time okay so what
was the story on that mom quit and went
home or what he did we had three kids in
that five and a half year period right
oh yeah I made a decision when the first
one was born that she was staying with
the kids and we'd be better kidded
towards that Scotch it very cool night
what do you do for a living I'm supply
chain director for a health care company
Oh mate okay good for you supply chains
a good field
very well done all right very cool
108,000 so what happened five-and-a-half
years ago that makes you think to make
you think you could or should get out of
debt we really felt like God was telling
us to do this and at the time I was
working and I had a friend who brought
the CDs and was just like check this out
I think guys would be interested and I
listened to it knows our she dish yes
okay I listened to it and I liked it I
took it home and he was just like okay I
listened to it when I get a chance and a
couple weeks later a couple at our
church so told us that they were going
to start teaching the class and I was
just like you know what this is two
times that we've been told about this
maybe we should look more into it and
then we decided to go to the class and
when we got the message on dumping debt
that was when we got it we're like we
absolutely have to do this one another
light it feels like there's light into
the tunnel so Financial Peace University
when you would get to the dumping debt
lesson the bells go off the whistles go
off and and the you hear the music Oh
getting out of that right you're gonna
get our attention yeah
that's a wild lesson yeah it's wild and
crazy' very cool so this is a long time
five and a half years it is you've been
scratching and clawing for a while it's
been a while well what made you able to
stay with it five years in a culture
where people can't stay with things five
minutes
well consuming the same note to each
other motivated we have plenty of
naysayers and people who challenge what
we're doing so we just stayed the course
and then I let us do motivate us from
what we were doing we know was the right
thing to do we know it's a biblical
thing to do and we made sure we stayed
steadfast in that direction so those
tough it was definitely difficult but we
just pull through it you know when
people are losing weight and they say
hey I'm on a diet very few people go oh
don't do that that's crazy everybody's
fat nobody does that
right right but when you're getting out
of debt everybody goes oh I don't do
that yeah you don't have that
everybody's got that whoever don't you
know everybody's got a car debt and it's
like it's weird nobody everybody
encourages you to lose weight get in
shape but when you're actually trying to
get your finances in shape you know the
broke people they all wanna throw
grenades over in your plan yeah yeah and
we talked about perks and all the perks
were missing out on and the purge yeah
the perk you're missing out on is one
hundred and eight thousand dollars or
that debt baby oh that's my perk I'm
free shut up I like it very good very
good what was the hardest craziest or
weirdest thing you did while you're
getting out of debt I lost ESPN oh man
so we cut back on everything you wanted
it back I did I just had the internet Oh
so again that I got ridiculed for that
like how do you not have yes yeah no
that's really serious right there ain't
it funny how we just look at something
like that we like act like that's
sacrificing yeah I mean when I was a kid
we could new spell ESPN you know we got
along fine without it it's hilarious but
oh my goodness well that's amazing
congratulations hey guys what what
advice do you give people when they walk
up to you and say man I got a hundred
ten thousand order that I can't do this
there's no way I can get out
well first thing I would say um ie the
secret if you will it is the budget the
budget and the envelopes
where are our I guess the thing that
made us be disciplined it really changed
our behavior you know because it was so
different than what we did before we are
so on a debit card credit cards and and
that that shift that paradigm shift is
what shifted our behavior because was so
different I mean my wife was pregnant
she was walking into the gas station to
pay for a gas pump the gas they go bad
for me they actually gave me a special
card I wouldn't have to carry the baby
in when she got here so that's those
type of things you know even we forced
herself to do it
once we forced it the behavior came
behind it and that's the behavior
behavioral shift so that was the secret
you know I doing a budget was very
revealing and then obviously doing
things differently following a program
then the behaviors will come behind it
so she's in cash were there are times
that you didn't think you were gonna
make it
yes yeah for sure how'd you pull through
that would you say Stace
um I know a lot of times I tend to be
the spender and he's the saver so when I
would get discouraged because we
couldn't go on vacation or because we
couldn't buy something that I wanted or
something that I just knew the kids
needed to have I would run it pass him
and and then sleep on it and say you
know he's probably right we don't need
that we can wait yeah that's the hardest
thing is the no yeah
saying no so that you can say yes yeah
you live like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
yes this trip yeah there you go well
you're an impressive couple you're very
fun to meet and to talk to thank you
thank you for your inspiration because
sticking with it five and a half years
is pretty amazing alright it's Nate and
Stacy and we a little one the little
ones the names are what yeah Madison
Madison for we got Kyle Nicholas is 7
months ok and Nicholas don't look like
he's screaming much he looks like he's
out of it yeah he's pretty much on nap
mode alright get the whole gang together
and let's have a great countdown Nate
Stacy and the team Cincinnati Ohio 108
thousand dollars paid off in five and a
half years making 125 then down to 77
then
up overtime to 128 count it down let's
hear a great debt free screen one two
three
good job you guys I love it I love it I
love it well done well done
you